[Music]
[Music]
there are a number of reasons why i
never covered this group in the past the
main one being that they aren't really a
faction at all
as the name suggests they're really just
rioters civilians that have chosen a
lawless path in order to survive
a large number of them was simply just
put in a situation where they didn't
have a choice
where others were small street gangs
who've decided to use this opportunity
to bolster their ranks and take more for
themselves
[Music]
in new york city the term rioters is
simply used as a name to group the
growing number of different hostile
individuals and gangs who are
unaffiliated with the other larger more
organized hostile factions
in contrast to the hyenas found in
washington dc these street gangs haven't
joined up under a single banner
in response to the breakdown of law
enforcement looters ransacked the city
as supplies began drying up these
looters turned to the weaker members of
the community
eventually these smaller groups of
scavengers started growing in order to
defend themselves against other groups
all right the guns check out
let's do this yeah but what if they have
kids just hold the gun like you mean it
they'll back down especially if they got
kids yeah
but what if they won't then it's on them
they don't have to die unless they
decide they want to it's their choice
this is some [ __ ] yeah but i'm not
gonna let some rich [ __ ] get a pass
just because i got a family
everyone's got a family and mine's
starving now man up and let's do this
they roam the streets and packs taking
anything of value lashing out at anyone
who is unfortunate enough to be caught
in their path
while they are disorganized and poorly
armed over time they have managed to
acquire a number of firearms and weapons
from other gangs and the equipment left
behind in the quarantine zone when the
jtf pulled out
the growing number of rioters are a
constant hindrance to the joint task
force efforts of re-establishing control
and the distribution of supplies to
those in need
like i mentioned there is no set
hierarchy for the rioter group as a
whole
though each gang has their own group
leader which more often than not would
be the strongest in the pack
they would usually be found carrying
better weaponry and armor than the other
members
however it isn't unheard of for pax to
join up to take down larger targets
especially when it comes to the jtf and
attacking supply lines though these
relationships would usually end shortly
after each
encounter but these aren't always
planned
being opportunists they can often be
found running in and joining the fight
with other gangs if they see some sort
of personal gain coming out of it
with the dwindling jtf numbers the
rioters show no respect for their
presence in the city and will attack
without hesitation
but when it comes to the other larger
factions of rikers cleaners and lmb they
know they are heavily outgunned and
unorganized so we'll avoid where
possible what about over by the u.n
gotta be a lot of rich people there
diplomats and foreigners gonna be easy
pickings man are you crazy
that place is like the killing fields
what do you mean have you seen those
guys over there
bunch of badass special forces types
with some serious hardware too top of
the line not that weak ass jtf [ __ ]
and i don't think they're going to give
you a trial or nothing either
they'll drop you as soon as look at you
so no way man anywhere but there
the rioter's true strength is in their
numbers
like the cleaners this is their city
they know the streets
they know the best places to use to
their advantage
if they can bring enough bodies they
have just as good a chance as anyone to
surprise and overwhelm even the most
organized group
these are the people who are a large
part of the reason the jtf were forced
out of the quarantine zone and the
subsequent fall of the first wave of
division agents
[Music]
outside of the smaller groups found on
the street the second wave division
agents first encountered the rioters at
one of brooklyn's precinct police
stations
they have taken control of the compound
and are holding several officers hostage
using the element of surprise the agents
quickly sweep through clearing out the
hostiles and freeing the men and
while moving through manhattan the
agents are tasked with assisting the jtf
with clearing out a location that would
become a forward operating base a place
that would later be known as the base of
operations
the agents come to the support of the
jtf and clear out the small group of
rioters occupying the area
though this seemed a little too easy it
was because the bulk of this group of
rioters had moved a little down the
street and had taken control of madison
square garden
hey like your stuff
i'm going to the garden what
i thought that place was locked down not
anymore
gts pulling out everybody's getting
together and we're going to take the
place over let's pack your [ __ ] man you
don't want to get left behind oh holy
[ __ ] is this for real oh hell yeah and
you better stack up this time i can't
cover for you if you won't pull the
trigger
not again all right and that goes for
anyone who gives you trouble cops jtf
civilians anyone
they get in your way
they're gone
this location had recently been turned
into a sarah field hospital
dr kendall and a number of sarah workers
were on site when the riot is rolled in
they were there to commandeer supplies
but also recognised the value of having
medical personnel under their control
the division was successful in rescuing
dr kendall and the cereal workers
but were quickly made aware of another
much larger group who were assaulting
the lincoln tunnel checkpoint
coordinated by captain benitez this
checkpoint is an integral part of the
supply lines for the jtf as it was the
only checkpoint leaving manhattan
given the large number of weapons food
and medicine running through this area
the gang of rioters sought to take this
for themselves or at the very least stop
the supply further crippling the jtf in
the area
though this group was considerably
larger and much better around than the
previous rioters that had been
encountered there were no match for the
joint coordination efforts of the jtf
and the shd
the rioters is just a label that is
given to the large number of gangs and
individuals who are either using this
event as a way to take advantage or
simply don't see any other option to
ensure their own survival
while they are disorganized and
inexperienced
their numbers make up the bulk of the
hostile presence in manhattan and are a
constant threat to the mission of
rebuilding society
now i couldn't make a video on the
writers without addressing probably the
most recognizable audio line in the
franchise
they got alex
the joke around the community is that
every rioter must be called alex
but my personal head cannon around this
is that sometime around the start of the
outbreak after the jtf had withdrawn
from the quarantine zone
when these groups and gangs of rioters
were starting to establish themselves
a man named alex was out there making a
name for himself
he was widely known and well respected
across the many gangs and groups
throughout manhattan maybe a community
leader of some kind
i like to think he was in the process of
trying to unite them into a single group
either as a large settlement type
structure or on the other side a
potentially even more menacing hostile
faction than we have witnessed today
either way this obviously didn't happen
our character or the division in general
was responsible for this
either targeted when things got dicey or
maybe caught in the crossfire
the division was responsible for the
death of alex
the reason they repeatedly call out they
got alex when in combat is to remind
their members of what we have done in
turn having them fight more ferociously
for their fallen brother
anyway that's my theory maybe alex is
just a really popular name in new york i
don't know
i hope you've enjoyed this well overdue
video and i'll catch in the next one
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]